moi ce que j'ai dit hier à Gérard
Larcher concernant le peuple corse le
peuple corse c'est une évidence c'est
une évidence historique c'est une
évidence culturelle c'est une évidence
linguistique et c'est une évidence
politique maintenant sa reconnaissance
constitutionnelle pose des problèmes qui
sont des problèmes considérable parce
que la Constitution française au jour
d'aujourd'hui ne reconnaît qu'un seul
peuple c'est le peuple français donc à
nous de trouver un chemin d'abord
politique et ensuite juridique pour que
cette aspiration à la reconnaissance du
peuple Corse puisse être prise en compte
par la République de la même façon il
est normal que le président du Sénat
réaffirme son attachement au principe
d'unité de la République l'autonomie y
compris l'autonomie de plein droit et de
plein exercice est également une
appartenance à la République française
donc je pense que là aussi on doit
trouir on doit pouvoir trouver un chemin
en tout cas c'est c'est ma volonté et
c'est mon objectif d'autant qu'à peine
le discours d'Emmanuel Macron devant
l'Assemblée de Corse fini votre collègue
lï Chen et Gérard qui préside la région
Bretagne a demandé la même chose pour sa
région est-ce que c'est la preuve que ça
peut être le début de de la fin de
l'unité de la République et et que ça ça
fait le jeu de ceux qui disent mais
l'autonomie de l'accord c'est une remise
en cause de l'unité de la République bon
notre objectif n'est pas de de dynamiter
la République ni de remettre en cause
ses valeurs et principes auxquels
d'ailleurs nous sommes attachés parce
que au-delà des valeurs et principes de
la République sont des valeurs et
principes universells qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs y compris dans dans la
constitution de Pascal Paul au 18e
siècle non moi ce que j'ai dit au
président ça risque de faire boule de
neige ça peut faire boule de neige sauf
que nous demandons notamment dans la dé
libération qu'il y ait un titre dans la
Constitution consacrée à la Corse
pourquoi parce que c'est précisément une
façon
constitutionnelle
d'encadrer le statut de la Corse et de
consacrer sa singularité la Corse n'est
pas une région de droit commun y compris
une région de droit commun à forte
spécificité la Corse n'est pas non plus
la Polynésie ou la Nouvelle-Calédonie
donc un titre et des articles
spécifiques consacrés à la Corse une
façon de dire il y a une singularité
force une île une île de Méditerranée
une situation politique qu'on retrouve
pas ailleurs une histoire
constitutionnelle qu'on ne retrouve pas
ailleurs et des aspirations et des
éventuellement des problèmes à traiter
et à solutionner qu'on ne retrouve pas
ailleurs et on le fait à travers d'
statut d'autonomie souénéris c'està-dire
adapté à la réalité de la
course